Hey, everybody.
This is Will, and I'm showing
you new features that we are
releasing in Hangouts
API version 1.1.
Now in this demo, I'm a giant
floating robot head.
And we're using the voice volume
to control my mouth.
However, the head itself is
being controlled by my head.
So I can tilt, tilt, zoom way
in, zoom back out again.
It's very cool.
So we've added a new message
data channel, which lets you
send low-latency messages from
your machine to everyone else
in the Hangout.
In this example, I can
draw with my mouse.
Which is fine, but it gets a lot
more exciting when we add
two different participants.
So in this example, I have two
Hangouts that are running
side-by-side on different
computers.
So if I draw in one, it appears
on the other one
nearly instantaneously.
This data channel is very
low-latency, but it is lossy.
So you are going to want to use
Shared State, that we've
already released, to keep
your Hangout in-sync.
Lastly, we have overlays, like
this one, which are not
attached to your face.
You can use them anyway
you want.
This one's reversed, because
it's mirrored, because I'm
watching it on my own machine.
Thanks for watching.